avez-vous bien réveillonner en famille
et vous mademoiselle anouk aimée est ce
que vous savez que les français en une
année on some soixante-et-une mille
tonnes de chocolat 138 milles tonnes de
bonbons et de confiserie sans parler des
385 milles tonnes de volailles et des
600 mille tonnes de foie gras de
charcuterie et de jambon et 1 milliard
400 millions d'huîtres dont le quart en
décembre
c'est à dire que les français déguste au
mois de décembre
près de 400 millions d'huîtres et toutes
ces huîtres il faut les ouvrir
évidemment à la main les unes après les
autres puisqu'il n'y a pas encore de
machines automatiques il savez vous que
c'est un français
celui ci qui est champion du monde des
écailles et william blais un enfant du
lot et garonne qui depuis 37 ans a
ouvert plus de 15 millions d'huîtres et
qui a battu en 54 le champion du monde
l'américain secteur en ouvrant semblons
en 3057 essayé et 114 end huîtres à
l'heure et si un jour un petit camarade
vous dit
la france vient d'être battu en football
ou au box ou au cyclisme vous pourrez
lui répondre très fièrement
oui mais nous en france nous avons le
champion du monde c'est lui le champion
du monde des ouvreurs d'huîtres
[Musique]